oh yeah welcome to this video yeah yeah
yeah I had requested that game and then
I got a phone call and then it started
and whatever it is kind of a mess okay
um Cherokee let's stick with what I know
Catalan Boogle territory that's not
exactly what i recommend in my book but
also play with line yeah we get the Holy
typical pawn structure for the for the
bogo Indian it's some pawns on dark
squares and black has gotten rid of his
dark squared Bishop so this is in
general a pretty good structure let's
see i can go i can have some interesting
ideas even this is a move if he takes i
cant capturing with both pieces is
feasible pawn takes or Bishop takes if
he's not taking I have a b5 for some
play on the queenside c6 was also
interesting maybe the better who've
actually okay so let's go b5 that was
the idea
just before ya gain some space let's do
that hmm I can take with the sea pawn
here right and night to see five it
looks inviting
hmm it looks very good for black
actually where is he going with this now
I don't think he had see takes before
expected
oh yeah man you should have tried not be
five okay i know i can go before but i'm
not sure about this you can also improve
a little bit more and then do this age
30 km it's kind of a nothing move and
here we go so um I can start with B 3 as
well I don't know is that the better way
to do it or just wish it takes I let's
just stick with the bishop it's okay
hmm okay I didn't expect that one now i
will get i will get this night c5 idn
ultimately i will have a very strong
pawn on the bee farm
yep so let's push the pawn um one thing
though now it's not necessarily yet but
I need I need some some looked for my
king g 6 h-6 kind of move Jesus probably
yeah okay 94
yeah the point is just they're doing a
home run
93 and B 2 and so on
that should be should be the easiest
just be to be one it's a bit of a self
pin that move but it doesn't matter i
can just promote the pawn
white resigns yeah it was a very nice
position at one point that's it I think
well this is all oh ok and here probably
probably c6 is a bit more more flexible
than what I did but this is not terrible
it's the playable move this one okay
maybe but now now that that that I think
he has to move from he has to move the
night night to be five was what I was
expecting and this is this is far better
because he's looking at the d6 poor now
and I don't want to take this is not a
good idea and this kind of thing is got
a protected passed pawn and he has this
this opportunity so after this I have to
play differently probably taking is
interesting even this is a move yeah
let's totally unclear interesting
position but after that I've instantly
much better because my night gets that
fantastic see 5 square and yeah thats
it's completely turning the game I mean
before it was probably in the in the
equal somewhat somewhat equal ish but he
I'm instantly having a huge advantage
with multiple ideas yeah and this is
this is in helping me and getting with
time getting the beep on rolling and so
on I didn't even needed to spend time on
a on a move like age 6 inch or g6 to
secure my background because the beep on
was was just too strong just too strong
okay well thanks for watching